foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to track three new
approaches in the genetics of disease
for lab Roots genetics virtual
conference April 20th to 22nd 2021 I'm
Rasika Mathias and I'm excited to talk
to you today about sequencing The genome
from genotype to phenotype and a few
extras in between
it's 2021 and time to say happy birthday
happy 20th birthday to the human genome
20 years since its sequencing and it's
perhaps important to take pause and just
think about how far we've come
20 years ago we were looking at complex
diseases genome-wide but we were using
panels of genetic markers on the order
of about 300 markers today we're looking
at complex diseases genome-wide but
we're looking at millions and millions
of snips thinking back to this recent
publication from nhlbi's Precision
medicine program 400 million Snips 53
000 individuals
we've come a long way and today if you
run a Nova seek for 24 hours you're
getting three terabytes terabases of um
readout in in a single 24-hour period so
that's pretty incredible to think about
and the cost of the human genome
obviously is declined rapidly along with
this we are now generating extensive
amounts of Next Generation sequencing
and in the next 30 minutes or so I'm
going to sort of walk you through an
example from nhlbi's Precision medicine
program top Med where we're leveraging
these genomes to call variation
corresponding to the dynamic genome or
telomere length and Chip if you will and
really hone in on the importance of a
multi-ethnic representation in large
Precision medicine efforts
the G was catalog today has close to
5000 Publications
um you know well over 200 000 trait
associations but really it's important
to think about where this representation
stands in terms of human populations
and a large fraction of This research
actually really is focused on
populations of European ancestry
we've made some Headway in bridging
these gaps here's an illustration 2009
to 2016. we've gone from 96 down to 81
European representation but really the
critical Bridge here has been Asian
populations uh populations of African
ancestry and Hispanic Latino populations
are very poorly represented still
what's interesting when you think about
this is that it particularly for African
ancestry populations the little blue
parts of these pie charts noted here
while we represent in these in these
studies a small fraction these studies
actually do contribute a much larger
proportion in terms of the discoveries
made
why does this matter
well let's think about the promise of
the polygenic risk war and precision
medicine opportunities the polygenic
risk score is our means to use and
leverage genetic discoveries to risk
classify individuals and sort of really
think about intervention and medical
interventions and therapies targeted for
individuals at high risk that can be
almost diagnosed before the onset and
that's that's this whole PRS framework
but what we do know is that there's
really non-transferability of the PRS
especially as the distance between
Discovery and application populations
grows even for something as simple as
height as Illustrated in this really
elegant example we know we do really
poorly when we take discoveries of
genetics and European populations and
propagate them onto non-european
populations
so with respect to the lack of
representation in multi-ethnic nature of
these data sets there are many issues we
grapple with four or here you know
disease biology Remains What not well
understood we're not sure of these
discoveries in European populations are
being replicated we're potentially
missing associations with disease traits
because these are discoverable only in
non-europeans and to be honest the
further away we are from the discovery
population the less likely we are to be
able to predict risk accurately and this
is perhaps the critical piece here from
a Precision medicine initiative and all
of these large amounts of biobank data
and large amounts of Next Generation
sequencing data that we're amassing
so I'm going to use this sort of story
which is you know a story in the era of
whole genome sequencing
um and and actually a bit of a lecture
on on the telomere chapter here with
difficulties that we mastered but
opportunities won in um in top Ed
telomeres
um they affect many aspects of human
health long art telomeres are generally
associated with a more increased cancer
risk uh telomere attenuation is
generally related to a host of
neurodegenerative diseases but I think
most notable is the relationship between
shorter telomeres and cardiovascular
disease in the literature but what do we
know about telomere genetics well
um as with that illustration I showed
you earlier telomere genetics is no
exception to the lack of inclusion of
non-european populations this is sort of
a slide where you see sample size versus
the the year of publication color-coded
by ancestry 17 G Watsons have been
published before 2020 13 of these in
Europeans uh foreign Asian only a single
one in African ancestry and one in
Hispanic Latino but I want to point out
that one in African ancestry is
extremely small all in its sample size
it's really important because we do know
from from extensive prior evidence that
telomere
is considerably between human
populations and is in fact longer in
African ancestry populations both in
comparing African Americans to European
Americans but even looking within
Continental Africa foreign so where do
we stand on the genetics at telomere
lengths we know it's a highly heritable
trait 30 to 80 percent we know a
difference between populations there
have been plenty of G was loci this is
actually grown rather rapidly recently
with the new UK biobank initiative
um prior efforts are all using
laboratory-based assays Southern blot
qpcr
um what we know is that cumulatively
these G wasp signals account for two to
three percent of trait variants but as
of now there really hasn't been a
sequencing based approach applied to
telomere genetics and so we really know
very little about causal variants
underlying these chuos Peaks
I mentioned a little bit about the the
southern blot and the qpcr and I just
want to give you a snapshot of the
Technologies and the tools we use to
measure telomere length without going
into much detail the point here is just
to say that there are a variety of tools
the most common use for large-scale
epidemiological studies is the qpcr you
know it's fantastic in that it's high
through good inexpensive requires low
amounts of DNA but it has some
challenges in terms of it being a
relative quantification it's a PCR based
approach and potential for high
variability in the assay
so here comes topmed we've sequenced 140
000 individuals in a real diversity of
backgrounds as shown in this pie chart
and all of a sudden now we have the
opportunity to address population
diversity and limitations of Prior G
losses because we can leverage this
whole genome sequencing data now to
actually estimate telomere length
bioinformatically from the data and to
perform genome YG losses of the wgs
generated telomere length so so really a
two for one we're generating a phenotype
using the pre-existing sequence data and
we're really going to be able to help
address gaps with respect to the lack of
multiple representation in Prior studies
what about estimating telomere length
then from the wgs data this is sort of
an area of opportunity sought and the
first question of course is can we do
this at scale in large Resources with
sequence data because remember these
large consortia level data sets they are
including Human Genome sequences
generated cross-sequencing centers
leveraging uh Legacy DNA Etc so of
course while we know we can do it by
informatically the question is can we do
it accurately somewhat accurately at
least
um can we do this at scale with these
large databases so this was an
opportunity we sought in in topmed and
we applied two different Tel and we're
calling methods the method tile seek and
the method computelle and really the
primary difference between the two is
computelle costs us a lot more in
computational time because it has a
realignment step
the first thing we did is to compare
these bioinformatic tool estimations of
telomere length from whole genome
sequencing to flowfish which is truly
like the gold standard here of of
telomere length estimation and in a very
small sample set where we don't have
major sequencing artifacts these are 20
samples freshly collected DNA all
sequenced together at the same
sequencing site we actually had
remarkably High correlation in the the
telomere length from the the wgs
I'll seek on the left hand side computel
on the right hand side and flowfish data
from two different cell types and as you
can see the correlations are really high
at about 0.8 and higher
so this looks great but this is a small
data set no major headaches of
sequencing artifacts
here's a slightly larger data set this
is this is about 2500 samples from the
Jackson heart study in top event and
over here what you're looking at is the
the correlation Intel seek that's panel
a on the left-hand side between computel
and Intel sync and we had really high
correlation in the telomere estimates
between the two the second point is
they're both somewhat similarly
correlated to Southern blot data which
as I pointed out earlier is a laboratory
assay used to measure telomere length
and on the right hand side however you
see that there's a major computational
trade-off
so the ultimate decision then within top
Med was to run telseek on all available
samples is the final Choice given this
computational cost and given that it
performed equally well
um between computel and telsi compared
to Southern block
however what I'm showing you now is that
very same plot layering in colors and
these colors represent sequencing plate
and it's immediately apparent that when
you go from a single study with a small
sequencing design to a large larger
study where sequencing was done across
multiple plates and Legacy DNA there's a
clustering by color and this clustering
by color is a sequencing technical
artifact that we we discover when we use
this sort of large level of data
so this is the difficulty we then
encountered in trying to do this in
topned however we were able to sort of
overcome this difficulty because we used
a batch correction tool where we are
using sort of a correction across the
human genome measuring average
sequencing debt every 1000 base pairs
and we were able to improve that
correlation between Southern blot and
telsique from about a 0.55 to 0.68 as
we're showing you over here so so
honestly we were really really excited
by our ability to overcome some of the
sequencing artifacts that we showed you
on a prior slide
the second point I think that's really
exciting is when you look at these two
phenotypic measures of telomere length
one measured from the whole genome
sequence data the other measured in a
laboratory assay that has really high
quality the southern blood
um they're genetically very highly
correlated in a family-based syllable
from Jackson heart and that genetic
correlation is 0.8 so that's sort of a
second confirmation that these two
things are really sort of measuring
um the very same underlying trait and
phenotype that we're interested in
acquiring
so how did top Med help us before I get
into this Manhattan plot of then
studying this telomere length we
calculated on 110 000 individuals I want
to remind you of this pie chart and top
Med this is the 109 000 individuals that
we're able to study and and put this in
the context of these two prior images I
showed you before the left-hand side
showing how much of a difference our
study in telomere length is compared to
um just the general catalog of GEOS
associations that little blue pie
representing African ancestry here
almost a quarter of our data is African
ancestry and the the sample size
um going from this little blip here of
500 individuals now up to 30 000
individuals if we just think about the
African ancestry component Hispanic
Latino
um there's not even that they don't even
Factor here on this right hand side in
terms of Prior genetics so so this is
sort of an exciting opportunity we've
created just innovatively thinking
outside the box from from a whole genome
sequencing data generated in in top end
um this is the Manhattan plot and we
have plenty of discoveries I just want
to sort of Orient you this this
um y-axis is split what you're looking
at is p-values that go up to 10 to the
power negative 10. the the green line is
1 times 10 to the power negative 9
that's sort of our threshold
um and what's shown is the the loci in
red are previously known the low science
blue are entirely novel so you know this
sort of innovative creative uh way of
leveraging whole genome sequence data to
do something really quite novel and
measure a brand new phenotype of
telomere length
um this is the sort of the part of the
dynamic Human Genome as I referenced
um all of a sudden has really added to
our our biology and genetics
understanding of telomere length
variability in in human populations as a
general discovery
um these loci actually amount to 36 in
total there are 59 credible Sentinel
variants in here and we're able to hone
in on Sentinel variants they'll show you
because we're using whole genome
sequence data for the street was
um 20 of these loci are novel
um but of course you know what's the
value of this wgs where you know zooming
in under the hood if you will and that's
the value to me over using the prior
g-wases
um this is a series of 10 loci
um where each little green line
represents an independent signal and so
for 10 of these loci we're able to to
sort of hone in under the peak and
really identify
um Sentinel variants that are
independent from each other so so we go
from loci now to actual Snips and I want
to sort of use one illustration which is
tarte we've thought of church here based
on the left hand side in Prior two
losses as a single Locus but you know
this opportunity has taught us that
there's a many many Snips involved in
this single Locus here there's five
independent signals all mapping for tert
the truth however is is I started out is
is if we're going to think about prses
what do these look like uh prs's off of
telomere length what do these look like
when you look at them in the context of
multi-ethnic representation so the left
hand side is just showing you what we
made in terms of discoveries putting all
of top Med together and then the right
hand side is flitting out the various um
ancestry race ethnicity strata in in top
Med and you you can clearly see like if
you just look at the purple variant for
example the purple variant is the peak
variant in the overall group but it's
not necessarily the peak variant in each
individual group in fact if you look at
the African-Americans this is the top
right panel it's not by any means it's
the third or fourth strongest
Association signal so you know this is
that idea of saying how important or
reiterating how important it is to not
just look at everything together but but
tease these things apart
so we used whole genomes to calculate
telomere length are we finding things
that are biologically meaningful here's
sort of a gene set enrichment using
these loci
um you know I I've just simply taken it
in the top 10 or 20 Gene sets there are
hundred that were very strongly
[Music]
um
significant and I just underlined the
word DNA or telomere and literally
everything in the top 20 is either
telomere or DNA so yes these genes are
definitely highlighting Pathways that
are telomere biology related
are these effects big or small well if
you look at the effect sizes that we
have discovered from this whole genome
sequencing approach we would argue
they're quite important you know
telomere length seems to decrease at the
average rate of about 25 base per year
in an adult in top Med we see effect
sizes of about 13 to 13 to 10 38 base
pairs per allele so you know this this
could cumulatively add up to a pretty
significant difference in telomere
length
um based off of these effect sizes
directly
what about answer ing differences so you
know I showed you just Peak Snips that
were different based on which population
we looked at but here's an illustration
at the 10 F2 Locus
um where if you look at the top white
panel which is the European ancestry
group in top Med you don't even see this
Association and so had all of our
telomere work been focused on on
European ancestry populations uh we'd
never have discovered tin F2 at least
not in in top Med and and this is sort
of a really important piece to to drive
home
um expanding Discovery to non-european
populations allows you to identify novel
signal that's not captured in in uh
leveraging only European ancestry
populations
but it's even more important than that
we actually have multiple variants where
there's true genetic heterogeneity
across the ancestry buckets so you know
this is this is not just a feature of
um Power and allele frequencies but it's
actually a feature here as we're showing
you in top Ed
um a matter of the actual effect size is
of course we used bioinformatic tools to
compute a phenotype based off of of
whole genome sequence data so the
question we get asked a lot is that's
really neat but do you replicate
um the the prior associations and and
more importantly do your novel
associations replicate other data sets
that use standard laboratory tools or
are these just some artifacts of
sequencing what I'm showing you here on
the the left hand side is comparisons of
effect sizes across our 59 Sentinel
variants to Prior Publications that use
qpcr and these red dots represent
um the the loci that are novel these are
the the loci in our data that haven't
previously been found before and as you
can see they're really highly correlated
so Ada replicate at a p-value threshold
for replication but B they're also
really highly correlated in a fetch size
which is what you're looking at on this
graphic
a second level of saying do they
correlate is what you're seeing on the
right hand side here we just limited our
data to the Jackson heart study a single
study uh that I showed you earlier
you've got Southern blot data you've got
telseaq data and if we limit it to the
single study and recompute the effect
sizes the effect sizes are correlated at
an R of 0.92 right
so so clearly we're we're able to
measure leveraging this whole genome
sequence data
um a a quantification of telomere length
that appears to work really well and I
want to say actually a a LD regression
score approach that takes our European
ancestry to us and Compares it to Prior
published g-was's so just looking at the
summary statistics between 2G wasps is
one on telsig derived telomere length
and the other on qpcr derived teler
mirror length yields a genetic
correlation of 0.81 so so really you
know there are so many different levels
of validation of this sort of approach
we've taken to measure telomere lengths
there's so much more and and sadly I
need to start
to sort of summarize it so I'm just
going to quickly give you brief
snapshots of the so much more without
going into too much detail
um the first one is that this sort of an
approach using whole genome sequencing
data has really enabled us to hone in on
rare variants and identify first and
foremost that there are rare variant
signals contributing to genes that we've
previously implicated from the common
variant and that's what's up here in in
green and then what's down in the bottom
in red is these genes that we're able to
identify that have only rare variant
signal and are not discovered by common
common variant gwas approaches
um both of these genes actually are
really intriguing biological candidates
for telomere biology so so that's super
exciting
foreign
so much more piece I want to want to
bring up here is we do have polygenic
risk scores that we've created off of
the The Sentinel variants the 59
Sentinel variant and we've applied this
to
um telomere lines PRS to bioview biobank
data and what we're able to confirm is
these previously documented findings
that a PRS for telomere length
um generally is associated with
increased risk for cancers these sort of
upward pointing triangles represent
increased risk for the outcome while our
our associations with coronary artery
disease were not significant I do want
to point out that in general you see
this reverse Association that I pointed
out before which is all of the triangles
that are red are actually flipped and
pointed downward so there's sort of this
this directional difference between
Cancer related uh risks for telomere
length and cardiovascular relay did and
these are previously documented and
confirmed from the genetic approaches
used in this particular sort of
opportunity
an additional piece on this polygenic
risk war is that when you compete
compute this PRS in the the bioview
African Americans and European Americans
we find something really interesting and
that is that the polygenic risk score uh
population distribution in African
Americans from bioview shifted to the
right so this is again really I think
confirmatory evidence of the phenotypic
findings right we started out learning
that telomere lengths are longer in
African ancestry populations
and what we're seeing here is that this
longer telomere length in African
ancestry population can indeed be
explained in part from the genetic
mechanisms that determine telomere
length at a population level
um and I think this is this is sort of a
really exciting
um uh bridging of the Gap that we've had
thus far in telomere line genetics
there is really you know other parts of
the dynamic genome that I want to Circle
and wind down with and these are again
opportunities to think about with a
massive amount of genome sequencing data
where we're creating here across all of
these uh consortia level initiatives
um and that is to really think about the
the dynamic parts of the human genome
that come from telomere length as you've
just heard about but also clonal
hematopoiesis and the prevalence of
clonal hematopoiesis in in driver genes
um and yet again another level would be
thinking about mitochondrial DNA copy
number and heteroplasmine all these
three pieces can actually be called just
by having whole genome sequencing data
at hand using bioinformatic tools so
this has been done and there's extensive
collaborative effort um again across
various working groups in in this
particular Consortium and you know I
just want to hone in on a few additional
exciting results to think about for us
here
um
Conor hematopoysis was called we were
able to quantify in in top Med
um sort of carrier uh carrier um clonal
hematopoiesis by by driver genes and
document this show that chip is of
course uh correlated with age graded
ship observed at greater age
um but work um going on to actually
study the G wasp of Chip so just as we
did in in the prior illustration where
we calculated telomere length and then
ran a giwas of telomere length both
sides of it coming from the whole genome
sequence data here this work was was led
by Alex Bick and pradeep natarajan
um and and many others in topmed where
they called chip and they ran a g was
for chip and um this is the Manhattan
plot from from this publication now and
what's exciting is that they landed on
two genes that we've known or we've
shown as well in the giwas or um for
telomere length so so you know two parts
of the dynamic Human Genome component
that we're measuring
um that are coming back to same the same
genetic loci
so this work has since been extended
um looking at the the clonal
hematopoiesis or chip in conjunction
with telomere length across these
samples and um what we were able to show
is that they're sort of here looking at
the left hand side that ship across
these driver genes in general is
associated with shorter telomere length
um you see it here for overall which is
the upper little black circle but you
see it based on on the driver genes
themselves if you look in fact at the
number of Chip mutated genes uh you see
sort of this you know overall
um in decline in in telomere length so
it's it's a really fascinating
um sort of bridging and bringing
together of two parts of the dynamic
Human Genome using
um these next Generation whole genome
sequencing projects and data sets
available and what we've discovered is
sort of this bi-directional mendelian
brand organization by bringing together
these data sets um the first is that
mendelian randomization studies indicate
chip causes shorter telomeres which is
what you're saying here but also we've
noticed that we've been able to identify
that the mendelian randomization studies
would support that long artelomere
length can in fact cause chip
acquisition
so I want to wind down with a final
take-home message and slide and that is
we have
created a wealth of opportunities with
Next Generation sequencing data we
typically tend to try to at least at
least from a genetics perspective we're
trying to connect genetics here on the
left-hand side to clinical phenotypes
and endpoints of Interest not just use
aging related phenotypes here as an
illustrative purpose right it could be
any phenotype we're interested in with
we're generating all of these massive
amounts of omics data transcriptomics
methylation lipidomics proteomics
metabolomics and we sort of try to to
bring together genetics and phenotype
incorporating these relevant pieces as a
functional component so sort of
upweighting these genetic connectors
based on their functional relevance by
integrating these these additional omics
we're being really creative in this
space maximizing the use of the data
using imputation approaches but I think
what we've really identified here in in
this particular illustration and
thinking a little bit more creatively
outside the box is you can actually push
the envelope even further to generate a
whole new phenotypes right and here what
we can do is really think about
leveraging omics to quantify new
phenotypes we've used the illustration
of telomere length you could think about
measures of biological aging
Etc
but really I think also to consider and
keep in mind jointly leveraging omics
from initiatives such as top Med to not
just expand the the use of the data in
these innovative ideas but also to
bridge gaps in health disparities by the
inclusion of multi-ethnic representation
so um I wanna
a final slide to truly acknowledge the
extensive teamwork involved here
um from the the telomere work
specifically there's a core team of
analysts and investigators and and you
know I just want to say that that team
science has been amazing and created
opportunities and that have really
pushed the boundaries of our our use of
the next gen sequencing data we have in
hand entitlement